at dawn residents of an apartment Block
in Kiev try to absorb what's happened
the building was hit during another
night of Russian drone attacks on the
City Emergency Services help a woman a
family in shock try to find comfort
able
the house shook a lot it was very scary
people really should be in shelters
because you just do not know where
things will fly
in daylight the scale of the damage is
clear shattered Windows upturned lives
people still shaken but starting to pick
up the pieces
this man salvages what he can from his
car others like Victoria wait to give
statements about the damage they've
suffered to authorities she lives on the
ninth floor
we were sleeping and heard a huge
explosion I grabbed my child and ran
into the corridor it was horrible I
didn't know where to go I was scared to
stay scared to go but when I heard
people scream fire I ran outside
since the beginning of May Russia's
targeted Kiev with nearly nightly
missile and drone attacks people say
it's exhausting and frightening
we've seen some of the residents come
out of the building with their
possessions in suitcases with their pets
leaving some people telling us that they
don't want to stay here anymore because
either they're building their apartment
has been damaged or they simply don't
feel safe anymore
this woman packs her car she says she's
leaving
yes I thought this might happen because
air defenses are constantly working
around us
is also going desperate for some respite
it's hard to speak I'm still in shock
still crying we won't stay here tonight
we have to go
City officials say Russia's not only
targeting critical infrastructure in
Kiev it's also trying to wear down
ukrainians and Crush morale there's no
doubt the nightly attacks are having an
impact but for now most people refuse to
give in to angry about a war they didn't
ask for
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Kiev
an Israeli has died